let's bring in the Hall of Famer Charles
Barkley joining us on the show Chuck
thanks for getting up early we
appreciate it how are you today no
problem my brother two things number one
I don't wish my daughter a happy
birthday
the best thing you haven't happened to
me my daughter Christiana and I want to
wish you happy birthday also my brother
Thank You Charles thank you I appreciate
who do you love more your daughter me
well I think it's a close call but I'm
gonna go with my dog all right fair
enough
all right I'm fine um it was close
though it's going to be close in this
series with Golden State in Houston I
don't think so I you know I there's
nothing I saw last night I picked the
word umpires but man I don't know if the
Rockets can win a game you know it's a
tough man they they pour the waters it's
just unbelievable I mean Stephanie even
played well last night yeah I mean it
was just that's the thing I said before
this series Chris Paul and James Hart
have to play great they have to play
great but it rockets to win step covered
and play well last night dream I didn't
play well last night but Kevin was
amazing play who's the best shooting
guard in the NBA was fabulous I mean
this team is really good man they're
unbelievable he'll do I don't think but
but how good are they you know I asked
Steve curry yesterday about this just
this starting five we love to do this so
why not do it now
it's Golden State up there with Bulls
teams bad boy Pistons the Celtics in the
80s the Lakers with Kareem and magic I
mean are they bad no it's it's hard to
tell because the way the game is played
now there's no physical contact but they
got three of the greatest offensive
players that the league has ever seen I
mean those three guys and the thing
about it you have to there's so much
space on the court because you can't
leave any of those three guys I mean you
can't cheat all stuff you can't treat
our claim
so Kevin gets to play one-on-one
all the time I mean that's a really huge
advantage I mean because you can't
believe that you mean you won't three
mine or whoever they put out there I'll
hit the dollar you want them guys to
shoot the ball but those three guys are
so good I'll festively
it's just nothing you can do man you
just gotta hope they have a baby can't
there's no good matchup for Kevin I mean
you you can't put you can't put a big on
that if I were to rocket I put Clint
capela on them these old one who you
can't stop him but he leases is 7 feet
tall somewhere in that neighborhood but
this isn't something the Rockets aren't
do I mean Golden State is just a better
team Houston has to play a perfect
series to beat them so it's not a knock
on Houston with something they did or
didn't do last night it's really Golden
State is just that much better they just
better I mean you know James had four to
one Chris had 23 in the rest of the guys
the way the Rockets play that's their
biggest problem I mean you can't just go
one-on-one against Golden State
I mean James and Chris got to play at a
much faster pace I think they just
dribble dribble dribble and shoot a shot
at the end of the shot clock
if it goes in it's great but if it
doesn't go in it's not going to be a
good thing for them so I wish they were
to attack more at the beginning of the
shot clock morning but excuse me go
there they're more unstoppable
yeah it's harden at the top of the list
now in the NBA
I said months ago Dan I said he might be
the most unstoppable offensive player
now he's not a good as good a player as
Jordan or Kobe but from an offensive
standpoint he might be the best in the
in the conversation with the best or
like Iceman Gervin people like that but
naga king was like that James Harden
might be the best officer he might not
score there you go he's able to get a
shot every single time and and his green
is Michael and Colby were you didn't
have to start guard them at the
three-point line but I do I think James
Harden like I said I said that particle
and people would like oh maybe you need
to think about that
this guy might be the best offensive
player we've had my league in a long
time and Kevin they can harass in the
same conversation yeah we were
mentioning this at the start of the show
and I said the thing that separates
Hardin from everybody else is he has a
great-looking shot and he can shoot deep
he can beat you off the dribble he's
gonna get you in foul trouble he can
finish at the hoop he can shoot a
mid-range jumper all of those offensive
you know attributes that you want and
it's very few guys who check the box on
all of those things in NBA history no
question you have heard of a cent
correct and like I see Michaels a better
player Cobras a better player well you
never had to start checking those guys
at three-point line or I mean and they
couldn't get to the basket every single
time but James Harden is is it like I
say James Harden and Kevin Durant out of
two best offensive players we have in
his league debate but James is special
charles barkley NBA on TNT Hall of Fame
analyst joining a Stan Patrick show how
important is the game tonight in Boston
for Cleveland I don't think it's the
most important thing in the world I
think that's going to be a long
drawn-out series I think if you look at
am and the Celtics
they got some tough matchup by the
Warriors excuse me for the Cavs
I mean Al Horford is a tough matchup I
think that Jason Tatum is scary good
Jalen Brownlee is scary good that and
the Cavs don't have anybody can match up
with them LeBron it's a pick'em series I
mean LeBrons don't have to go crazy if
the Cavs gonna win this year the man is
gonna be it's gonna be a hell of a
series well that's the only play out
started I thought the wars and rockets
to be a six seven game series knock-down
drag-out I don't feel like that after
getting one but after watching that game
Sunday the Celtics against the Cavs is
going to be a six seven game series and
it's a pick'em series I don't think the
Cavs have to win tonight well let me
tell you something this is
they got so many holes you know we
talked about the Cavs defense all year
is my things they don't have any answer
for some of the matchups ethically
though that the Celtics I mean get
batting hanging some great credit rest
even some great credit about all the
players they're taken man they're doing
a fantastic job they got a great game
plan against LeBron
but the main thing maybe if you go back
and look at the 76ers series Jalen Brown
and Tatum they attack all bad defenders
because I was on the sixes who were good
shooters they just kill them offensively
and those guys for the Cavs they are
going out there they hit them in a hit
every single time if I said you can have
Jason Tatum's future and our Ben Simmons
oh what a great question Dan Pollard
right now would have to go with Tatum
because he can do it all the incentives
got to get better out sensibly but
that's a great question if you ask me
right now I probably go with Tatum I
asked Reggie Miller yesterday I said if
I blindfolded you from three-point range
and you were shooting against Ben
Simmons now I doesn't have a 3-pointer
in his NBA career yet would you take
Reggie Miller blindfolded from
three-point range or Ben Simmons he's
really got a lot of work to do on this
jump shot man I mean when Reggie said
that Reggie would beat Ben Simmons
blindfolded I think if you could Reggie
Reddy's one of the greatest shooters
ever I don't want to insult the end but
let me say you know the good thing about
it you know they played a bad Miami team
the first round of the playoffs so you
know you know I was talking about this
last night two weeks ago it was like the
Sixers of going to the Conference Finals
yeah could they be the bad Miami team
but then we saw when they played as a
team is really well coached and got a
strategy they
looks not very good so you know strategy
matters in the MBA and then some of
these little players is mani still got a
long way to go a long way to go yeah but
I'm trying to figure this out with
somebody who has that much ability but
doesn't have a shot and Reggie said you
got to get him into the lab he just got
to keep shooting jumpers they said no
you're gonna keep shooting the same
jumper that's not a good jumper you need
to you really have to have somebody help
and break it down a little bit here and
that's hard to do when you get to this
point I know he's only what 20 or 21
well you have to understand something
bad a lot of these guys they're so
talented you can get through high school
and college on talent but that does not
work in the NBA you see it I would just
van you see a lot of these guys who go
to college you're one and done I mean
you look at Donovan Mitchell is
fantastic Jason Tatum is terrific but a
lot of these rookies are awful because
they have played the game strictly on
talent their whole life and now they're
not the guy who can run the fastest jump
the highest
they got no idea how to play basketball
I mean you go back think about a Ben
Simmons played great against Miami
because Miami got no they're not
inaccurate but then when he played
against Tatum guys like that jaylen
brown Taylor Rozier he wasn't big he was
bigger but he wasn't stronger faster and
could just outrun him in jumpin and he
really struggles and that's what
happened to a lot of young players who
come to the NBA
didn't they because they've been the
best player of their whole life but when
you get to them being you're not the
best player so he's being you're like oh
yeah I got a long way to go and that's
what happened to Ben and that second
round of the playoffs do you remember
what you did your rookie year from
three-point range I would be surprised
if I shot any threes my rookie year I'd
be totally surprised I got you one for
six well that's you know bit
like guys everybody's gotta shoot
through my canteen I'll tell things I
says well if you got clay stuff and
camping around you can live and die by
threes but one the problem the NBA got
now is hey those are the three best
shooters in the world now we got every
loser out there now surround the shoot
threes and got everything out dig guys
out there shot at you trying to shoot
threes
I mean what's one thing these teams
gotta learn you don't have to shoot
threes I mean that kid Baynes is a doing
a hell of a job for the Celtics you know
you know Greg Monroe came in and played
to have a bit but for some reason every
team want to try to see three just
because the Warriors got their three
best shooters who ever lived
and it only worked with those three guys
was it awkward at all last night you're
at the game and you've had some words
about draymond Green
did you see draymond Green before the
game I saw him after the game I got
nothing against any of these players I'm
on you know I shouldn't have said what I
said about punching him in the face you
know it is really weird the kids a good
player he's a very good player and I
like him I like him I've never had any
words with him but I'm a you know what I
said at the time I meant I mean even
last night he goes out there just
knocked the hell out Jane hardens no
reason that was uncalled for unnecessary
he's that picky said in the backcourt
was a cheap shot I didn't like that but
kids a heck of a player but you know I'm
gonna do my job I'm not out here to make
friends
did you talk to him I did not I don't
normally talk to these players I stay
out of these players away I stay at a
different hotel of these players even
when we even when we stay at the same
hotel these whether I make them move me
to a different hotel because you know I
don't have to criticize these guys at
times so I always move hotels the best
pen in the same hotel because the last
thing I want to do is punch one of these
kids I'm not worried about getting
punched myself I've been punched many
times but I don't want to punch either
these kids
you know if I point to you imagine if I
punch one of these guys and it hurt him
and they wouldn't able to play if they
hurt me and ain't no big deal but I'd
probably get fired and and that would be
stupid on my part but but I'm gonna do
my job no matter what I was like a dream
I was a very good player but some of
this stuff just drives me crazy you're
playing as simple I think I'd have to go
with draymond Green against you know
Charles he's too little bad he's too
little
pretty big to me Chuck he's only about
six seven he's too little
I'm not too much about little guys well
I think you weren't afraid of Shaq
either so I'm not afraid of anybody dad
I'm not really afraid of anybody
I'm pretty good at there could you beat
up all four of my dance at the same time
probably at 25 you can think good yeah
yeah but not at 55 not at 55 Ritchie's
got some arms she's kind of thick man
well don't you know that's like when you
fighting a guy who's got muscles I says
that doesn't bother me when a guy got
muscles I'm a big ol muscle he's like
Jeremy kicked my butt all the time I
said hey I'm not worried about them big
ass muscles you got I won't be hitting
you in your face and your head I mean
I'm not gonna be one of those guys who
hit you in your shoulders and you know
for everything I'll be hitting you right
in your eye should the NBA embrace
legalized gambling here you know Dan
first of all the notion that people
don't gamble on sports it's ridiculous
and silly you mean I love to gamble
I didn't even I don't even know I mean
the notion that you have to go to Vegas
I've bet on sports is certainly it
should have been legal a long time ago
but I feel the same way about Gemini
feel about pot I don't smoke pot I smoke
pot probably five times five times in my
life and all it did make me want to eat
potato chips so I don't get those and so
now they got a legal pot everywhere it's
not gonna make me throw out a stars
spoken it so I feel the same way about
gamblin just go they got gambling legal
and people who don't gamble aren't gonna
rush out to the casino places like that
that's my opinion
I don't even know what it means just
means a bunch of rich guys and the
government don't make a lot more money
that's that's all it means I mean the
government man as much as I love this
country and it's a great country Phil we
got some issues it's kind of like the
marijuana thing I mean big it used to be
illegal to put all these guys in jails a
father should be into if I don't make a
lot of money on it
and now they just gonna make a lot of
money on gambling so that's the way I
look at it to be honest which of my
brother I'm not gonna run out I always
gamble I'm always going to gamble but
this notion that people are gonna order
Gama's legal now
everybody's gonna go out and start again
and I don't believe it I told you I feel
the same way about pot I don't smoke pot
not as illegal I know I'm not gonna
start smoking it now do you bet on the
NBA games the finals playoff game what I
bet on the finals
do you have you read on them I bet on
basketball before yes do you have a bet
on this playoff well you could have
taken Golden State to start or you know
you could take this take the Celtics
over the Cavs you could win some money
you know what I told you that's a
pick'em series that's a pick'em series
III I'm not ready to count the Cavs out
yet but I think that's a pick'em series
then plain and simple
but I tell people man you got to get us
up to some credit what they've done
is incredible I mean what they've done
is incredible
and like I say we were talking last
night would it be better for the NBA
if these Celtics for the Cavs get to the
finals and I say it from an NBA
standpoint it probably better if LeBron
plays because he's one of the greatest
ever but from a basketball standpoint it
probably better for the wars to play the
Celtics you think that Celtics would
give the Warriors a better game are
better series yes yes I do yes I do I
really do I think most people think that
I mean they know the cows are not gonna
beat the Warriors I mean LeBron would do
his thing but they would not be Tim I
think the Celtics would be a much better
matchup against the Warriors I mean I'm
much better not even my matchup a much
better matchup from a basket I'm curly a
basketball standpoint Chuck thank you
for getting up till the boys we settle
oh and happy birthday your daughter
thanks happy birthday to you my brother
I appreciate your friendship and keep
doing your thing man you do a fantastic
job Thank You Charles
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]